[Musique]
on est où là c'est magnifique tous ses
livres dans mon bureau
bonjour barbara cassin bonjour et merci
de nous accorder cet entretien vous êtes
philosophe philologue académicienne
aussi et les listes et ça tombe bien
parce qu'on avait envie de revenir avec
vous sur les mots de la crise sanitaire
ces mots qui se sont imposés on va
partir tout simplement
de ce mot de crise qu'est ce qu'il
signifie ce mot de crise et quelles sont
les racines de ce mot crise ça vient du
grec krinein qui veut dire juger et donc
ça donnait beaucoup de mots en français
comme critique par exemple ou critères
et en fait c'est le moment où ça bascule
c'est à dire que quand on juge ça peut
passer du blanc au noir on peut être
coupable innocent on peut être guéri ou
mort et on ne sait pas encore de quel
côté on va basculer non mais parler de
crise c'est ça c'est dire attention on
est sur une ligne de crête et
sachons de quel côté on va tenter
d'infléchir la chose alors ce mot aurait
pu être le mot ducobu de 19 le mot de
crise et pourtant c'est un autre mot qui
s'est imposé depuis des semaines on va
l'écouter c'est emmanuel macron le 16
mars dernier qui l'a prononcée et qu'il
a même martelé
nous sommes en guerre en guerre
sanitaire certes nous luttons ni contre
une armée n'est contre une autre nation
mais l'ennemi est là invisible
insaisissable qui progresse et cela
requiert notre mobilisation générale
nous sommes en guerre
déclarer la guerre déclarer la guerre
voilà il l'a d'emmanuel macro la guerre
il dit qu'il déclare la guerre vous dit
le président de la république lorsqu'ils
disent ah oui c'est ça c'est sa fonction
d'ailleurs un c'est le président de la
république qui est le chef de l'exécutif
qui déclare la guerre est là c'est bien
ça nous sommes en guerre c'est une
déclaration au sens strict de guerre
alors il la déclare la personne il a
déclaré au virus mais c'est à dire un
ennemi masqué invisible et ca1 sommes
pas des hommes pas un autre pays mais il
fait sa fonction de chef de l'exécutif
c'est à dire qu'ils déclarent la guerre
est-ce qu'il est approprié à la
situation ce mot selon vous il a sans
doute une fonction au moment où il l'a
prononcée c'est à dire quand il a fait
cette déclaration de guerre il a voulu
faire un choc et faire en sorte que
qu'ils ont les français
de saisissent de main du
drame sanitaire qui était en train de se
jouer on nous a dit qu'on était en
guerre avec les attentats les attentes à
2015 à nouveau en guerre avec le virus
est ce que les mots gardent leur sens à
ce qui est un risque que ce mot là si
particulier perdre totalement de son
sens est ce que il faut voir pourquoi il
est utilisé de quoi guerre est-il le nom
voilà il est le nom de la permission de
se rassembler derrière un chef et
d'utiliser des moyens qui ne sont pas
disons moyen de paix de l'égalité de
démocratie
la licence d'aller un tout petit peu
au-delà de ce qu'on devrait faire si on
était en paix à ce mot de guerre barbara
cassin c'est ajouter toute une série de
mots un champ lexical qui nous renvoie
aussi à la guerre je pense à ces zones
vertes ces zones rouges le mode au
rationnement le mode attestation le mot
de perly première ligne être au front
les deuxièmes lignes dans quelle
ambiance à nous mais ça à quoi ça nous
renvoie surtout dans quel rapport au
monde ça finit par nous nous influencer
nous structurer oui bien sûr c'est fait
pour pour qu'on ait peur est que ces
peurs nous permettre
de nous comporter correctement c'est à
dire de garder la distanciation social
comme on dit et d'effectuer les gestes
barrières et de ne pas aller voir ceux
qui sont malades et de pas embrasser ce
qu'on a envie d'embrasser la peur nous
rend docile obéissant discipline et oui
il n'y a pas grand chose d'autre à part
l'intelligence
séoul a peur ou l'intelligence
et le président de la république a
choisi la première option selon vous
non il est trop intelligent pour en
avoir choisi que la première option mais
il a misé sur la première option pour
nous rendre intelligent il ya une
expression aussi qui a pu surprendre
brigade d'ange-gardien celle là c'est
c'est le ministre de la santé olivier
ferrand qui l'a utilisé lors d'une de
ses conférences de presse
ça vous surprend cette expression la
savoie rock
c'est une absurdité grave
bon brigade ça va quand même ça rappelle
des souvenirs pas très agréable quand on
a vécu la dernière guerre moi j'ai des
amis de l'âge de mes parents qui sont
devenus
horrifié à cette mention cd souvenir
impossible donc on peut pas parler
brigade alors brigade d'ange gardien
est ce que ça change beaucoup de choses
de mettre la bible et le catéchisme avec
brigade j'suis pas sûr on va jeter un
voile pudique sur ce terme fait c'est de
la maladresse caisse comment comment
expliquer sa housse et de l'amnésie
c'est quoi
il n'a pas l'âge
d'être vraiment de souvenirs vraiment
des choses oui il est probablement
maladroit mais bon disons que on peut
oublier
simplement alors ça serait bien que les
anges gardiens en soit c'est à dire que
par exemple
il puisse faire en sorte que et bien
dans les foyers qu'ils vont visiter où
il n'y a peut-être pas de quoi bouffer
il apporte
il pourrait protéger pas seulement
protéger de la maladie mais protégé de
tout ce qui tue à côté de la maladie et
en même temps que la maladie les
brigades il faut le rappeler il s'agit
dans la bouche du ministre des personnes
des équipes chargées de remonter au fond
les différents coups contact qu'à
contacter des personnes contaminées il
ya une forme de d'inversion des des
choses selon vous non c'est
malheureusement pas vraiment inversé
leur brigade contient ça moi je vois
dans mon quartier partir des brigades de
motards et là j'ai bien envie de parler
de brigade alors je veux dire qu'il y
ait des brigades d'ange gardien mais
alors qu'ils fassent un travail d' ange
gardien je comprends je vous soumets un
nouveau mot
distanciation social alors celui là tout
le monde l'emploi il vient également
de nos élus de nos représentants au
départ
comment on peut comprendre ce mot là
pourquoi n'at-il pas été utilisé à
l'expression de distanciation physique
qu'est ce que c'est la distanciation
sociale est une erreur c'est une erreur
de casting une erreur de vocabulaire
évidemment que c'est une distanciation
physique je peux comprendre
distanciation qui veut dire que nous
avons à être actif pour tenir nos
distances
donc éloignement est un peu plus comment
dire passif ou
exige moins d'action
alors donc mettons distanciation mais
social c'est absurde sociale ça a l'air
de vouloir dire et malheureusement ça
risque d'avoir été aussi le cas que ça
creuse les inégalités sociales social
est quand même le mot qui est à parier à
une égalité donc
la distanciation physiques locales celle
qui
détermine la distance de non contagion
moindre contagion entre deux personnes
parce que
social pour moi c'était vraiment eu une
erreur de vocabulaire encore l'ubs le
mot de déconfinement alors le mot de
confinement il est plutôt réservé au
milieu carcéral il s'est imposé dans
notre quotidien c'est peut-être celui
qu'on a le plus utilisé
est celui de déconfinement alors ces
nouveaux pas oui peut-être que c'est un
néologisme le prêt mais en plus on n'a
pas le droit de les former on va pouvoir
former le confinement est pire
déconfinement ça c'est les trésors de la
langue française c'est quand on peut
c'est le lego de la langue française le
confinement dias est ce que ça dit la
seule chose c'est que au point de vue du
signifiant c'est un peu moi je peux pas
m'empêcher d'entendre dès qu'on finit
par ce que vous voulez qu'on parle de
confinement bon donc le signifiant me
gêne mais très bien mais ton
déconfinement airs confinement ça va
arriver
mais au lieu de déconfinement là je
proposerai ouverture c'est à dire que ce
que je vois se profiler dans les
lycées dans les collèges
dans l'instruction
pédagogie dans l'instruction publique
c'est des
45 pages de préconisations qu'on envoie
aux
aux directeurs d'école et aux
professeurs et c'est très bien qu'il y
ait des préconisations et qu'elle soit
qu'elles soient énoncées comme
exactement comme
comme si on était un pilote d'avion
qu'il faille bien vérifier que chaque
chaque sexe la grippe à qui a 45 pages
bon revenons peut-être au mot
d confiné oui alors ça vient d'où déjà
confinement ça vient d'où donc fin
finissent là là ce qui a donné la fin
d'ailleurs c'est la limite la frontière
et on est confiné c'est à dire qu'on est
entouré de frontières pris dans les
frontières on est des cons fine et on
pousse les frontières on les enlève et
on va re confiné en les remettant mais
justement à des confirmands où j'avais
un professeur de philosophie qui m'avait
dit un contre-torpilleur c'est d'abord
et avant tout à leur meilleur ben
déconfinement c'est d'abord et avant
tout la fin je regarde mes instructions
de déconfinement un confinement et je me
disais que au lieu de déconfinement
pouvait m'ouvrir alors ouvrir tous les
lieux fermés c'est à dire les
bibliothèques les musées les théâtres
les salles de sport les plages
les les musées surtout tout bon ouvrir
ça aux enfants c'est à dire ouvrir la
société ouvrir tous les possibles
disons de dehors de la société les
ouvrir à tous à l'aide de ce qui
aujourd'hui sont on se bourre chômage
partiel
et qui ne demande qu'à travailler
intelligemment à savoir justement outre
les enseignants aussi mais les guardians
square j'ai les
guardian musées les bibliothèques heures
les conservateurs et rethel et les
sportifs je propose l'ouverture
la grande ouverture de la société dans
un temps qui est ni vraiment scolaire ni
vraiment vacances et qui rassemble et
qui permettent à ceux qui n'ont jamais
vraiment eu l'occasion d'aller dans un
musée ni l'envié mais bien de leur
donner cette occasion et cette envie
merci barbara cassin je voudrais pour
terminer vous posez la question du
pouvoir des mots que vous connaissez
bien ces mots-là ces mots de la guerre
ces bocaux qui vivent avec nous ils vont
nous suivre longtemps ça va laisser des
traces
ils vont co vivre
il faut qu vivent avec nous non je sais
pas ça sera on est quand même très libre
et très libre d'utiliser les mots qu'on
veut très libre de de vivre
en
ouvrant ou fermant
voilà ouvrons les mots aussi mais la
philologue que vous êtes considère qu'il
ya eu beaucoup d'erreurs commises dans
l'emploi ou le choix même d'un certain
monde bah oui mais c'est toujours le cas
vous savez les philologues sont toujours
d'un cheveu voilà merci pour cette
analyse des mots de la crise merci
beaucoup barbara cassin mercier
[Musique]